I started hearing whispers
about Thrawn’s return
as heir to the Empire.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
This is the way. Star Wars just announced
Three new movies all taking place
in three different areas of the timeline.
So we'll break it all down,
revealing pretty much
what the future of the franchise
is going to be the next couple of years.
So have you been wondering
about where they're taking the franchise
outside of the Mando verse
they've just told us in it all?
It takes place
in very different parts of the timeline.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
of course I'll do videos for everything.
Be sure to subscribe to get the videos.
It's just the beginning of Star Wars
celebration.
There's a ton more stuff they're going
to reveal the next couple of days.
Like who's playing grand?
Admiral Thrawn I think we've already
figured that out though.
And what's going on with the next
two years of Star Wars just in general?
I in my operations here
and for the rebels about peace by beings,
they they'll be the architects
of their own destruction.
There were also
a ton of brand new trailers
I just didn't Ahsoka trailer
so I'll link that at the end of this
and down to the description below
because the first big movie
that they announced and it's a really big
deal, is Dave Filoni
directing the Mandalorian Thrawn movie
that will tie together
all the overarching heir to the Empire
Grand Admiral Thrawn plots during this
part of the Mando verse timeline.
They literally referenced Heir
to the Empire,
the original Thrawn trilogy,
during the Ahsoka trailer.
So my bet is right now early theory
is that they'll call that Thrawn movie
heir to the Empire like star Wars.
Heir to the Empire.
This is Dave
Filoni actually talking about that movie.
One of the terms we use is,
you know, the war between the New Republic
and the Remnant Empire.
So we're going to see, you know,
you need a conflict.
And I'm, you know, just kind of looking
at a lot of the things that were written
over the years in various
expanding universe projects, trying
not just to look at what John and I did,
but we're looking at what was done
kind of historically in the time
period as a guide, I think, for,
you know, generations of Star Wars
fans before the era of,
you know, episode seven, eight, nine,
that was what we saw.
As we turn to the Jedi era,
when you're talking about
story and characters,
I think, in the expanding universe.
So there's a treasure of things to
to draw from,
not just within our own series,
but in the bigger galaxy.
Notice how Dave Filoni is explaining
that they're mining
a lot of the expanded universe
that they set up in the nineties.
In that original Thrawn trilogy,
The Heir to the Empire trilogy, basically
because when Disney bought Star Wars,
they basically just turned everything
into legends and said,
No, no, that's not Khan anymore.
All this expanded universe stuff,
we're going to skip over
and do completely new stuff.
But if you were around
during the very early nineties,
like a lot of us, you'll probably remember
that we did not think that
there were ever going to be more Star Wars
movies after Return of the Jedi.
We thought that that was it.
So when the expanded Universe
came along the Thrawn trilogy,
that was basically our Star Wars sequel,
and it is still an amazing story.
If you haven't read those books, I'd
recommend you go back and you read them.
That all started long before George
Lucas had ever announced anything
approaching the prequels.
He hadn't even started work on them yet.
So now in present day, Dave Filoni, Jon
Favreau are basically just taking
all that stuff and turning it into movies
in a live action series.
It's all playing out in The Mandalorian,
the Ahsoka Series, Skeleton
Crew, all the other connected series.
During this part of the timeline,
we're calling it the Mando verse,
but the Thrawn movie is meant to be like
their version of the Mandalorian endgame,
like the culmination of all the plots
during this part of the timeline.
But it will not be the end
of all the shows in this part of the time.
I don't continue,
but it'll just be the culmination,
kind of like the way that Avengers
endgame was a culmination for the MCU.
And then they continued
making Marvel movies
after that ages that now
with the announcement
of these different new movies,
different parts of the timeline,
they're going to be branching out
to other parts of the timeline,
which we assumed
that they would always do.
So, for example,
Ahsoka is a mandalorians spinoff.
I just did a trailer for that series.
That'll be the next place
we see Grand Admiral Thrawn.
He was feature
very prominently in the trailer,
or the back of his head
was as I was making this video,
they literally confirmed
all our theories that it is Lars MIKKELSON
coming back to voice the character
he did the voice during Star Wars rebels.
He was fantastic.
He's already been a long time,
fantastic actor in live action stuff.
Most of you probably remember him
from the Sherlock series
with Benedict Cumberbatch.
Everything's available for a price.
You make me an offer, a Christmas Present.
And what are you giving me for
Christmas, Mr. Holmes?
And yes, he is the brother of Mads
Mikkelsen, whose character is constructing
the Death Star
in a different part of the timeline.
Although his character
would have been around
during that part of the timeline too.
But Thrawn didn't really have anything
to do
with the construction of the Death Star.
He was working on different projects
during that part of the timeline.
We'll be talking a lot about Thrawn
this year between The Mandalorian Series
and what they're doing with him on Ahsoka.
Those episodes are coming out in August.
Of course, I'll do more videos for that.
When we get more footage,
we learn more about the series.
But right now on The Mandalorian,
because that series is connected,
they just screened Season
three episode seven a couple of days
early in the last two episodes.
Without giving away
spoilers, our total bangers
and they totally save the best for last.
A lot of people complaining about what
the overarching plot in The Mandalorian
is during season three.
Well, we find out pretty quickly
during episode seven and episode eight,
and they'll use those episodes
to push directly into this grand
Admiral Thrawn plot that happens on Ahsoka
and then continues on the other series in
future seasons and into the Thrawn movie.
So like I said,
they're basically doing Star Wars
heir to the Empire with the Thrawn movie,
but they're swapping
some of the characters in like Grogu
who wasn't in the original Thrawn trilogy.
Here's the thing though.
That movie will probably be the last
of the new three that they just announced,
just because they'll be so many more
new seasons of Ahsoka The Mandalorian.
There's just a lot of story
that they have to do,
and they just started to set up Thrawn,
the actual first Star Wars movie
that's coming out.
It's supposed to be Christmas
2025 in the reports are that it will be
the one Damon Lindelof was writing set
during the new Jedi Order 15 years
after the rise of Skywalker,
they confirmed that it will follow Daisy
Ridley's Rey, who is returning
15 years later.
She'll have become a Jedi master
and is basically doing the same thing
that Luke Skywalker is doing right now.
On The Mandalorian,
trying to create her new Jedi Order
with a little bit of help
from the sacred text
which she joined
when she left Luke Skywalker.
So those were not burned
when Yoda burned the old Jedi tree.
When they start releasing footage for that
in the next year or two,
when we started getting trailers for it,
we can start talking
about the fallacy of the Jedi Order
and how it kind of grew stagnant.
In one of the reasons
why Luke Skywalker's Jedi Order failed.
When they say Rey's new Jedi Order,
I think the whole idea
that she's going to be basing it all
on slightly different concepts,
it won't be the exact same thing
just over and over and over.
If she were to do the exact same things,
teach the exact same lessons
as the previous Jedi,
that just be repeating
the mistakes of the past
and it would just lead to their downfall
again.
Here's the thing though.
In a lot of you realize this immediately
when they said this further forward
in the timeline,
Grogu would be close to the same age
that Yoda was
when Yoda became a Jedi master, meaning
that Grogu would be hitting peak grogu
you force powers around this period.
He would long
since have become a full mandalorian.
He probably has some crazy beskar
armor too.
He be as large physically as Yoda,
and he could speak basically normally
like Yoda in Seattle, even though only
Yoda spoke that backwards speech style.
If you didn't watch Tales of the Jedi,
we got a whole bunch of Seattle back story
that explain what happened to her
during the prequels.
The council is leaving for a new book.
The funeral is to be held and
she was voiced by Bryce Dallas Howard,
who directs a lot of episodes.
That just implies that when Grogu
eventually starts speaking normally,
he'll speak like everybody else.
The thing about Grogu appearing in movies
further forward to the time
like an older grogu who Jon Favreau
and Dave Filoni have been very, very cagey
about whether they let Grogu appear
in other people's movies
because that movie would basically drop
between seasons of Ahsoka the Mandalorian,
like before the Thrawn movie comes out.
And if you see an older Grogu
you just kicking ass
15 years after the rise of Skywalker
just being a total badass,
it would kind of spoil
what his fate is during this earlier part
of the Mandalorian timeline.
Remember
Yoda's race lives for up to 900 years
and he wouldn't have even hit 100
when that new Jedi Order movie starts.
They didn't say they're bringing Finn back
for any more force training or if Poe,
the other characters in the new trilogy,
would return.
My assumption is that a few of them will,
but mostly it'll be new characters,
and that's why they're setting it up
for 15 years after the rise of Skywalker.
If that movie does well, like in Success,
they'd set up a new trilogy
based on the new Jedi Order that would
just follow those characters forward.
I think one of the reasons
why the new trilogy failed
is because they didn't have a plan
going into it, like they didn't know how
they were going to end the trilogy,
and it sounds like they'd fix that problem
heading into the new Jedi Order movie,
where they know where the story's actually
going before they start working on it.
One of the other more
interesting new movies they announced is
they're planning on releasing a James
Mangold movie about The Dawn of the Jedi,
that 25,000 years ago.
Originally, Dan
and Dave from Game of Thrones,
you may remember
we're developing a trilogy of movies
set during this time period,
but then they left in disgrace.
So good riddance.
James Mangold picked up the concept
and he announced he's going to write
and direct the movie.
So it'll be his original story
that he's writing for the movie,
thinking about what kind of genre movie
within Star Wars I'd like to make
and I thought
about a kind of biblical epic
like Ten Commandments
and a Dawning of the Force.
Where did the force come from?
When did we discover it?
When did we know how to use it?
And the story just started developing.
And with the wonderful help
of all the brilliant
candidates and brilliant
historians of Star Wars
and the timeline, we came up with kind of
an incredible story
to tell about the dawning of the force
25,000 years before before,
before this guy made his appearance.
So it's an exciting story,
and I can't wait to tell you
the idea of where it all started to make
it kind of Star Wars zero, if you will.
Where was the force born?
To me, a movie always has to have
a question to answer some singular thing
that you can say.
It's about not just connecting
plot of who built this,
when and who's going to defeat,
but what's it about.
And to me, this is about discovery.
He just finished doing Indiana Jones
five Trial of Destiny, so he'll probably
talk more about the Dawn of the Jedi movie
after Indiana Jones comes out.
It'll take him at least three years
to get that movie out.
So at current pace,
I think that's why Star Wars
is finally releasing a movie
every two years
that gives them until 2027 to release this
first Dawn of the Jedi movie.
They have covered that part of the
timeline extensively before in the Legends
canon and there have been references
to the original Jedi in the new canon
during the Mandalorian,
the sequel trilogy, even during Star Wars
Rebels, which they're now doing in live
action during the Ahsoka series, Everybody
hoping to see the band do show up.
If you look at the new official Star Wars
timeline, the symbol for that part
of the timeline where all those movies
and those Disney Plus series will take
place is the same symbol
that was on the floor
of the very first Jedi Temple on Oct two
that Luke Skywalker had been living.
And the picture is of the being
who was the very first Jedi in the black
and white coloration on him.
Dividing him was meant to represent
the concepts of the light
in the dark side of the force
in how those first Jedi believed in a more
Ben do like practice of the force
where they will did both the dark
side in the light side
face.
I feel like
I have a dark
and it enabled them to wield the force
in a more complete way,
be way more powerful than the modern light
side Jedi or the modern Sith.
But that Dawn of the Jedi franchise,
if we're talking about villains,
is probably going to be more like a Jedi
Civil War type of franchise.
If they do sequels to it
and they start doing Disney
Plus series set in
that part of the timeline, essentially
they would become their own main villains.
What happened in that part of the timeline
is there was a schism
in that original order,
and out of that
the light side practitioners
broke from the dark side practitioners.
They fought a bitter civil war.
A bunch of people die.
Eventually they both retreated
to different parts of the galaxy
and just fully developed
their own practice of the force,
only wielding either the light side
or the dark side in the new canon.
Not talking about legends.
The very first Jedi Temple was on Oct two.
After that you have the schism,
the Civil War,
the dark side, the light side, break off
and go different ways.
The light side practitioners continue
calling themselves the Jedi Order and move
the Jedi Temple to Titan,
which we saw on The Mandalorian.
That's where Grogu,
who use the ruins of the temple to contact
Luke Skywalker through the force,
I believe for a brief period.
The original Jedi Temple was also on Titan
in the legends
canon too,
while the Jedi Temple was still on Titan.
They moved some of the temple
to the planet office,
which is also from the legends
canon as well,
where they kept the Great Jedi Library
and they used the planet
just as a Jedi retreat.
That's where
right now in the timeline, Luke Skywalker
chose to create his new Jedi Academy.
We saw during the book of Boba Fett
where he was training Roku.
Eventually, we know Kylo Ren destroys it
with the Knights of Ren years later.
Then, about 4000 years ago,
at the end of the Great Sith War,
right at the tail end of the Old Republic
era, the Jedi moved the main
Jedi temple to course on where it remained
until Revenge of the Sith.
Fun fact two after Order 66
and Revenge of the Sith,
the Emperor turned the old Jedi temple
into his own personal residence.
There's just his twisted sense of humor
right now.
It seems like the release plans
for the new movies are.
They're doing the new Jedi
Order movie in 2025.
Then the Dawn of the Jedi movie
after that.
Then the Mandalorian Thrawn, heir to
the Empire movie at some point after that.
That's why I say they're going to continue
to have seasons of the Mandalorian Ahsoka
Skeleton Crew, other spinoffs.
Before we do the Thrawn heir
to the Empire movie,
they could always speed up
their release plans
for the movies and do one movie per year.
But I think when they start out
like right at the start here,
it'll be one movie every two years.
They might ramp up a little bit later
in success if things go well.
We're taking baby steps right now.
They've had a lot of successes
with the different Star Wars series.
So I think they want to lean
more heavily on that
and then ease themselves
back into doing Star Wars movies.
But for those of you
that wanted them to cover
earlier parts in the timeline,
like the Old Republic Era Do series
set during that period, set
during the Dawn of the Jedi era,
it sounds like they do have plans
to do that. Eventually.
There were a whole bunch of other trailers
and teasers that dropped,
so I'll do videos for those
as soon as possible.
This weekend there was an acolyte trailer.
There was a Star Wars
Skeleton Crew trailer,
which is also a Mandalorian spinoff.
There was also an Andor Season two trailer
as well to My full Mandalorian Season
three Episode seven video
We'll post next Wednesday
after they release it for everyone
publicly.
Please don't post spoilers for that.
If you did get a chance to watch it early,
everyone click here for my full Ahsoka
trailer video
and click here for my Mandalorian Season
three Episode seven Video Added the link
as soon as I post that.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys for the next one!